my identity is made by what my parents
think I should be getting to what you
really want to do is impossible I
believe that the best basketball player
in the world is not Michael Jordan
I'd love to dream but I also love that I
can you can always be a bit open to
maybe then there's other things rise and
shine it's an espresso time what's up
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message be exposed to new experiences
over to you Jay Shetty at 18 I was
really fortunate when I met a monk and
this monk was invited to speak and I
kind of just went because when my
friends forced me to at that time I was
listening to CEOs and entrepreneurs and
business people and marketers who who I
thought that's what I was aspiring to be
like and then I hear this monk and he
captivated me like no one had ever
captivated me before it was like staring
at the most beautiful woman on the
planet you know I was completely fixated
on him and his message see we live in
echo chambers we're just surrounded by
the same thinking how often do you bump
into a monk you know it just doesn't
happen you don't have no one has a
dinner party and goes oh yeah we listen
by the monk you know from a town like
the local monk like no one ever does
that and so you meet people who are just
like us most of the time and we talk
about this in business all the time if
you want to be a billionaire spend time
with billionaires if you want to be a
millionaire spend time and millionaires
if you want to be a tech startup spend
time you know that's that's the common
rhetoric that we hear all the time but
what if you want to find a purpose and
master the mind there's no one better
than a monk who's mastered the mind so
so for me the first step is just opening
yourself up to new experiences and new
role models because most of us can't see
ourselves in people so then we try and
fit ourselves into the box
is that we do see and and I mean there's
this beautiful quote that I've been
saying it everywhere and I wish I wrote
it but I didn't so it's by a philosopher
and writer named Cooley and he said that
today I'm not what I think I am I'm not
what you think I am I am what I think
you think I am I understand that blow
your mind for me it's a it's so powerful
I'm not what I think I am I'm not what
you think I am I am what I think you
think I am so we live in this perception
of a perception of ourselves
hence my identity is made by what my
parents think I should be my identity is
made up by what my college or university
thinks I should achieve while you're
living in that bubble and that echo
chamber getting to what you really want
to do is impossible because maybe that
just doesn't fit and I think so many
people feel that way today that they
don't fit into the current education
system they don't fit with the three or
four or five careers that you're taught
exist so that process of self excavation
and actualization first requires being
exposed you can't be what you can't see
if I never saw a monk I would never have
wanted to be a monk if I never meet a
billionaire I wouldn't want to be one
because I wouldn't know what that feels
like I don't know what it looks like I
don't know what it takes and and I think
that's the biggest challenge of our
society that we're not exposed so that's
the first step being exposed to unique
experiences and role models second step
is finding that experience or role model
that you're passionate about and exactly
like you said taking it seriously
shadow their network with them spend
time with them observe them even from
afar it takes that observation being
addicted to observing that person's
lifestyle and then the third step is
growing yes or no does that work for me
not everyone who's gonna go off from
become a monk is gonna feel like the way
I did and that's cool but not everyone
is gonna go and follow and shadow a
billion anger that's exactly the
lifestyle I want they may want the
result but do they want the hard work
that goes with it and so for me that's
the third step its observing focusing
shadowing getting as close to the
process of that individual and they
going yes or no do I want that process
not do I want the result everyone wants
to be that monk who's fully enlightened
you know can walk through as an
incredible or that people just gravitate
towards but when you realize he has to
wake up at 2:00 a.m. every day and
stitch about four to six hours you're
like ah you know I don't want to do that
that doesn't sound like me you don't
know what you don't know when you can
really wrap your head around this when
you realize that you think you know what
you want you think you know the path
that you should be going down but you
actually don't know until you go and
experience it and there's an entire
world out there that you don't have a
concept of until you start seeing yes
and trying things until you embrace that
until you recognize that you don't know
what you don't know you're gonna be
constantly living in this box of what is
known to you and that's a very limited
life I have a philosophy it's really
served me well which is I like to say
yes to everything at least once I'll say
yes to it once and just see how I feel
about it try not to judge it and just
say yes experience it and see if it's
for me and if I want to go back and do
it again so three quick examples of
things I've said yes - I tried rock
climbing
I tried snowboarding and I tried salsa
dancing I tried rock climbing even
though I'm afraid of heights I don't
like Heights they don't suit me well but
like okay you know what I'll go once
we'll see what it's like I got in the
harness I wasn't a huge fan of it I was
afraid of the heights the harness was in
my crotch it felt tight I didn't enjoy
reaching for the next thing it just
wasn't a fantastic experience for me and
I know I don't want to hate on rock
climbing I know a bunch you guys
probably loved it amazing awesome do it
you're the best rock climber in the
world it's not for me and I tried it I
tried snowboarding I became obsessed
with snowboarding I went every single
day one winter snowboard I got my board
I went every day I pushed off meetings I
was answering emails on the on the ski
lift up and I got decently good I was
carving I was doing some jumps I was
obsessed with it for a little while and
then it fell off I went every day in one
winter then the next winter I went maybe
four or five times with Nina and then
the next winter I stopped and I didn't
go back this winter either and it's gone
I haven't gone snowboarding we're
probably gonna sell of snowboards but I
tried it I know what it's like mad
respect everybody who loves snowboarding
it's a great rush I'm just not
interesting anymore
I tried salsa dancing on paper salsa
dancing would not be great for me I
don't speak Spanish I'm tall I don't
know the steps I didn't learn any
dancing growing up I take giant steps
you know learning as an adult is
difficult I don't understand the beat
and the rhythm of the music lots of
stuff kind of working against me
compared to people who have done salsa
their entire life and it's part of their
culture but all right I'll try it why
not no judgment let's go in and just see
how it works and you know what I kind of
liked it so I went back and I did it
again
and I did it again and the obsession
level wasn't even that of snowboarding
so born in Italy I was hooked I need to
do it immediately salsa I slowly picked
up steam I got better and better better
better better and Here I am now running
owning investing in the largest salsa
dance school in Canada for sure maybe
North America and so you never know
where things are gonna go if I only knew
what I knew right I started this message
with you don't know what you don't know
I didn't know that I would be great and
have tons of fun that salsa dancing I
didn't know that I would want to invest
in a salsa dancing business I didn't
know all that stuff I didn't know until
I tried it and even when I tried it for
the first time it wasn't with the
ambition that this has to be my next big
business one thing led to another led to
another led to another I followed what I
was excited by follow what I enjoyed and
then led to this and so in general
taking the approach if you're saying yes
just stop judging things and say yeah
somebody advise you to go do something
say yes somebody invites you to a new
restaurant say yes try this new food say
yes try this new dance say yes you limit
yourself we limit ourselves by default
we just say no we're built-in to say no
because probably biologically somewhere
in our history we have this fear of new
things but you will never discover what
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
what you could be the best in the world
Pat if you're not trying a whole bunch
of things I believe that the best
basketball player in the world is not
Michael Jordan the best basketball
player in the world is an accountant
right now because he never picked up a
basketball because he never tried
everybody should try basketball
everybody should try Italian food
everybody should try to be not from her
every way that you try to launch a
YouTube channel everybody should try as
many things as possible especially
early on in life don't get locked into a
certain path only because this is what
your parents want you to do this is what
the family has always done try that path
it may be great for you but chances are
it's not like most people don't end up
wanting to be like their parents most
people end up being like their parents
but they don't want that and you're too
afraid to break free of the tradition
you're too afraid to go down this scary
path but that's that's the path you can
be great at that's the path that you
have Michael Jordan level abilities and
talent and ingenuity act and you will
never know unless you try new things get
exposed to new experiences and say yes
now I've been really special bonus
clipped I think you're going to enjoy
but before that I want to know what is
one thing that you need to say yes to
that you are dying to say yes to that
today you're gonna say yes to what is it
leaving the comments below and by
writing it down you're committing
yourself to actually do it you're
getting results out of just watching
this video so you're not only watching
content on YouTube you're actually
making a change in your life what is
that thing you're going to release and
say yes to for the one person who's
listening to me is gonna actually do it
put it in the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of an espresso
and enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
like I said I'd love to drink but I also
love that I can you can always be a bit
open to maybe that there's other things
you want to do too
that's also something being an actor
that thing of I think it's maybe a good
thing to be open to they could do other
things it's a bit like when I decided
not maybe to act because I thought that
my life was taking another turn and that
was suddenly the first I mean a door
actually opened for me to give them the
chance to act and I think to do other
things and to kind of step out to this
industry and and have other experiences
will hopefully give you more tools to to
act so maybe maybe that could be was
something go away and do something
completely differently things get back
to it I think it's probably good to step
back from one's work for a while and and
try something totally new I think it
does revitalize your original enthusiasm
and that's what it has been like for me
over the last few years and now that I
have ventured back into something that's
very personalized it does seem that
there's been a lot brewing and and it is
just thank god this is visual if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details